in the global race for coronavirus
vaccines
biontech pfizer was first out of the
gate
a proud achievement for biontech the
german company that went from startup to
pharma superstar
now in the debate over waving patents on
covet 19 vaccines
the german government is siding with
drug makers saying
the protection of intellectual property
is a source of innovation
and must remain so in the future the
limiting factor in the production of
vaccines are production capacities and
the high quality standards
not the patents germany says
industry and government should work on
transferring technology to new
manufacturers
if they want to scale up vaccine
production quickly
and in a jab at the biden administration
german health minister yen span had this
to say
if the real problem isn't patents but
production capacity and availability
then i'd be delighted if the united
states is now willing to allow the
export of doses manufactured there
just like the european union
the us is just one of the wealthy
nations accused of vaccine hoarding
extending their immunization programs
far beyond their vulnerable populations
while poorer nations go without the
pharma industry says
that problem should be fixed first
but it's pictures like these from crisis
hit india
which have brought the problem of
vaccine shortfalls into sharp focus
prompting more than a hundred countries
including now the u.s
to support patent waivers as a way to
boost global supply
for many global health advocates it's
the right way forward
companies have earned a tremendous
amount in this this year alone on
coveted vaccines 7 billion us dollars
per pfizer
that seems like more than a sufficient
amount to be investing in innovation in
the future
moreover patent protection didn't
deliver the vaccines that we have now
significant government intervention and
government investment
from across the world has done that for
us
in india meanwhile the pace of
vaccinations has fallen
sharply for these people help from the
global community can't come soon enough
joining me now is stefan lieber he's a
member of parliament for the opposition
socialist left party
uh mr libby what do you think about the
german government's move to refuse
a patent waiver
i think this is a very very bad decision
if we look at our neighbors it's a
polish government or as a french
government
or at the secretary generals of the
world health organization
or of the un general secretary antonio
guterres
everyone is supporting this waiver only
the german government
is on the side of the pharmaceutical
industry
i don't think that this is a very wise
decision well critics say a waiver
would have very little immediate impact
because of bottlenecks in manufacturing
and and delivery of vaccines
what impact do you think a waiver would
actually have
we have seen this this report from india
a few minutes ago and the indian
government
was asking begging on the side of south
africa
for such a waiver they are not all
stupid people there and over a hundred
governments are asking for this waiver i
don't think
that the german government is much wider
if it is only bringing
a little bit to help this covet crisis
we should do it
as a trade representative of the u.s
government catherine
taylor has said we are in
extraordinary circumstances and this
needs extraordinary measures
we are supporting the us government but
our government
doesn't the german government said
intellectual property is a source of
innovation
pharma companies have invested billions
into developing these
do they have a point
yes but the german public the german
taxpayers
have invested a lot in those companies
so we have helped them to invent all
these very very important vaccines
and we don't want to cancel intellectual
property rights at all
it is just about the covit 19 vaccines
and i think this would be a very
a good and very important step well
pfizer is already
of selling their vaccine cheaper to low
income countries on a non-profit basis
don't you think that's enough
i'm on the side of india of south africa
of over 100 countries of important
organizations like
doctors without borders and so on i
think
you could back and wait to
do some gifts from companies but you can
make decisions too and this is what
states are about and this is what the
world trade organization is about
and i i really cannot imagine that the
german government would block
such uh such an action if the u.s
government is supporting it
stephen a member of the member of
parliament
for the opposition socialist left party
thank you very much
thank you and joining me me now for more
on this is thomas queenie he's the
director general of the
ifpma that's the global association of
pharmaceutical research
companies are you opposing this patent
waiver
and if so why
the patent waiver wouldn't really
address the problem because when you
look at the images speed from
india and nepal which we have just seen
we need immediate action and immediate
action the best we can do right now is
we need more solidarity from the rich
countries with the poor countries
because of the indian emergency
situation
supplies from indian manufacturers to
kovacs the global solidarity initiative
have trickled and we need to act fast
what we see right now is you have the
u.s and some other rich countries now
vaccinating healthy young
adults and in africa we have almost
nothing
therefore we need those shares from
which countries europe started
de vevo wouldn't give you a single
edition dose right now
because the bottlenecks are different
and we are deeply conscious of
doing everything we can leaving no stone
unturned to expand capacity
and by the way to work with the
developing country
vaccine manufacturers we have 275
partnership deals we have more than 200
technology transfer i've
just 10 days ago held a media conference
with the leaders of the
indian vaccine manufacturers and they
said the same as we did
the focus on patents is basically
ill-conceived
because it wouldn't address the need for
know-how transfer for
ensuring that those manufacturing paid
the vaccines
do have the skill sets
pfizer has already sold 3.5 billion
dollars
worth of this vaccine and critics are
saying
um pfizer and other drug makers have
made enough
uh alrea enough sales already through
this
pandemic wouldn't you agree
this is not about you know making money
when i look at we have had
several of the largest vaccine
manufacturers like msd
like sanofi like gsk they don't have a
vaccine
yet which means you had companies like
fisa bioentec
succeeding johnson and johnson as far
zenica and what they are doing is acting
socially responsible they do sell
these vaccines at not for profit or at
forecast or even below cost
to developing countries that's what we
need to do they do
team up with partners in developing
countries
we do have new partnership for example
with the company like bayer or novartis
they were not even in the vaccine
business they have now come
to help out and that's what's happening
we have
convened co-convened a global vaccine
and supply chain manufacturing summit
where we looked at what are the problems
the problems are the trade barriers
starting by the way with the united
states with the defense production act
which hinders exports of ingredients to
india
to problems of scarcity of raw materials
and it's not
quite true that you know the private
sectors just benefited
from public money when you look at
bioentec or modern or the two with
messenger r
day technology this goes back 30 years
and they got a lot of confidence
thomas queenie there the director
general of the global association
of pharmaceutical research companies
many thanks
thank you